Let's now talk about data center networking
and how network operators perform traffic engineering
inside a data center. First of all,
what characterizes a data center? Data center network
has 3 important characteristics. One is multi-tenancy.
Multi-tenancy allows a data center provider to
advertise the cost of shared infrastructure, but
because there are multiple independent users, the infrastructure
must also provide some level of security and resource isolation. Data Center
network resources are also elastic, meaning
that as demand for service fluctuates, the
operator can expand and contract these resources. It's also, can be pay per use,
meaning that as the need to use more resources arises or disappears,
a service provider can adjust how much resources are devoted to the particular
service running in the data center. Another
characteristic of data center networking is flexible
service management, or the ability to move work, or work loads to other
locations inside the data center. For example,
as load changes for a particular service,
an operator may need to provision additional
virtual machines, or servers to handle the
load for that service or potentially move it to a completely different set of
servers inside the infrastructure. This workload movement and virtual machine
migration essentially creates the need for traffic engineering
solutions inside a data center. A key enabling technology in
data center networking is the ability to virtualize servers. This makes it
possible to quickly provision, move, and
migrate servers and services in response to
fluctuations in workload. But while provisioning
servers and moving them is relatively easy,
we must also develop traffic engineering
solutions that allow the network to reconfigure
in response to changing workloads and migrating services.